driving today might feel like you're
using a tech gadget
especially if it's a car developed by
chinese automaker x-pung
first you'll need your phone to activate
the features and you need to
scan it then you'll give commands
and when you get to your destination the
vehicle will perk itself
these features are all part of x-punk's
strategy to stand out in the world's
second biggest market for electric
vehicles
the company is competing in china not
only with ev leaders like tesla
all-electric f-150 lightning but also
traditional automakers like ford and gm
which are doubling down on producing
electric vehicles too
technology combined with mobility and
auto
is where we think the future is going to
be one high-tech feature automakers are
racing to build
full self-driving capabilities but
putting more tech in vehicles creates
engineering challenges
and also risky behaviors it's totally
asleep
like tesla x-punk is trying to push the
boundaries of integrating tech into our
cars
and has gotten into a spat with elon
musk over software so we went to
x-pung's r d
lab to understand its vision for driving
we are working out a very unique culture
and capability that allows to
rapidly innovate will be able to be one
of the top players in china
has always operated like a tech startup
since it was founded in 2014.
we have a lot of the traditional auto
background employees
at the same time we have staff coming
from leading technology companies
brian goo is a former j.p morgan
executive who took over as
x-pung's vice chairman and president in
2018. we actually dedicate
close to 40 of our staff in the r d
area in software so i think that's very
different compared to traditional auto
companies
goo was the man behind x-punk's ipo on
the new york stock exchange last year
that raised 1.7 billion dollars
using this money expunge hired more
engineers and poached talent from
china's top tech companies like tencent
and alibaba
and one of the big goals for this larger
engineering team is to develop
self-driving technology
currently expunge offers what it calls
advanced driver assistance systems
this controls the car on a highway but
you have to keep your hands on the
steering wheel
in five years x-punk's goal is to
develop a fully autonomous vehicle that
doesn't need anyone in the seat
to make this happen it's invested a lot
in software and hardware
we are keeping basically investment in
autonomous driving as our
number one priority shinzo wu leads
expungs autonomous driving division
its software decides when the car should
accelerate or break and that relies on
information that comes from a vast array
of sensors
plus the most recent exponent cars are
going to be equipped with a special
piece of hardware called lidar which
uses light waves to map what's around
lilac can do a range calculation to get
a kind of a 3d
world view we can make a ton of driving
the city safer
lidar is expensive typically costing
about a thousand dollars apiece
and x-pung's latest car will take two
the company will be the first automaker
to mass-produce lighter equipped
vehicles this year
and its entry point will be lower than
35 thousand dollars
but x-punk's tech strategy has some big
detractors
is a fool's errand expensive sensors
that are unnecessary tesla is taking a
different approach and instead
investing in software that can interpret
what's on the road using only regular
cameras
tesla has very much tried to do
self-driving on the cheap
um with the the bare minimum number of
sensors that they can that they think
they can get away with
sam abul sammit is an auto analyst who's
been analyzing ev tech features for the
past 10 years
during a recent road test of ev
self-driving capabilities
tesla came in first by a big margin but
able simon says
x-pung system has more potential because
of its hardware
with the right software you can do
distance measurement but it's never
going to be as accurate or as reliable
as what you could do with active sensors
like lidar
a lot of sensors and cameras potentially
mean the self-driving software is
receiving more useful information about
what's on the road
just compare xpung's 32 sensors in its
latest sedan
to the 12 sensors and 8 cameras in a
tesla vehicle
tesla didn't respond to a request for
comment but musk has tweeted several
times
that its camera based system is more
precise than sensors like lidar
but the tesla and x-punk rivalry goes
beyond choice of hardware
it all came to a head when tesla filed a
lawsuit in 2019 against one of its
former employees in the u.s
who had quit to join x-punk the lawsuit
alleged that he took copies of the
source code of tesla's current driver
assistance system
in order to hand it over to his new
employer in court documents tesla
alleged the chinese company was inspired
by
and on a mission to beat tesla and has
transparently imitated tesla's design
technology and even its business model
in april tessa settled the lawsuit with
the former employee who acknowledged he
shouldn't have saved the source code
but said he didn't provide it to expunge
xbox said the engineer no longer works
for the company
and that its in-house developed r d has
been its competitive advantage
i view tesla as our partner rather than
competitor
tesla never brought that claim against
our company
which means that there is no evidence to
point any
wrongdoing but if there's one challenge
that the two rivals are facing together
it's the uphill battle with the public
perception of their prized
tech there's a growing sense that
the driver assistance systems that they
have the capabilities have been oversold
edward nedermeyer is an industry
observer who pushes for self-driving
technology as a way to make roads safer
okay tesla let's get this trip started
but he says social media video showing
some drivers operating a tesla from the
back seat
shows how dangerous these systems can be
when people are not using them properly
there's considerable
research that shows us people are much
more likely to misuse those systems
if they overestimate their capability
tesla has repeatedly said the features
it offers make driving safer
meanwhile expunge is working on a
driver's test acknowledging that a
self-driving system has limitations
for our drivers to be able to unlock the
autonomous driving features
they actually need to take a test we
also need to educate the drivers
how to properly use those technologies
so while expunge hones its self-driving
capabilities engineers are beefing up
other tech features like its voice
recognition system
or making its battery management
software super efficient
xbone has already started selling cars
in norway and says these tweaks will
help it crack the larger europe market
and someday the company plans to have
its cars on u.s roads
right alongside tesla vehicles